melania trump dropped an nft collection
promised to save the kids and people are
pissed and also very happy let's talk
about it ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the 10 million studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and wow i could not have
predicted this i yes i did expect
influencers to get involved yes i did
expect actors to get involved but the
former first lady what are we doing here
she just dropped an nft collection
melania trump i mean if you didn't
believe nfts were mainstream before it
now should be pretty obvious i mean look
we're one step away from the trump coin
i mean quite honestly the biden bucks
we're we are very close to campaign
fundraising that is just purely
coins and ponzi schemes right that is we
are very close to that and uh i just
thought i would salute
salute the grifters out there you guys
are
taking it to the next level right before
christmas you know i made my scam rewind
and people said i i made it too soon
because there's so much of the year left
i said you guys are crazy but look at
look at us now you know i couldn't have
seen this coming now before we get into
specifics here i feel it's important to
remind everybody i don't hate nfts i
hate the marketers and grifters doing
the cash craps in the same way i don't
hate your politicians of choice i don't
care right it's the scams right and left
to right the thing they both agree on is
they love making money off of their
tribal base who thinks that the left is
bad or the right's bad or whatever
because they know they're untouchable
they're they're untouchable with their
fan base and we're going to get to that
in a second because this nft grift is
just
it's historic it's legendary and let's
talk about it melania trump dropping an
nft art thing okay limited time edition
guys that's what
that's what edition it is what edition
limited time so here's the art piece
right here it comes with a little audio
recording we're gonna listen to that
real quick put the cans on and from the
press release they said that this is
melania trump giving us all hope okay
you can buy hope a message of hope from
melania for 181 dollars in solana my
vision is here we go look forward with
inspiration
strength
and courage and that's it actually
that's that's all you get 181 dollars
that's that's what you get now i think
it's important to read the actual press
statement here because this thing's
amazing excited for this new venture
which combines my passion for art guys
she's passionate and commitment to
helping our net nation's children
fulfill their own unique american dream
guys melania is not fulfilling her
american dream of keeping getting rich
no no no this is for the kids we're
doing it for the kid it's always about
the kids guys you have to understand
that and if you're wondering how it's
about the kids well read up a portion of
the proceeds from the melania trump nft
collection will assist children aging
out of the foster care system by way of
economic empowerment and with expanded
access to resources needed to excel in
the fields of computer science and
technology with a keyword there being a
portion of the proceeds guys never has
there been a word carrying so much of a
sentence that that word portion is
really just ah it's carrying this
because guys a portion of the proceeds
doesn't mean a hundred percent it
doesn't mean fifty percent it doesn't
mean one percent it means anything um so
if i raise a million dollars and i give
a portion of the proceeds to save save
the turtles i could give a penny and
technically that would be a true
statement a portion of the proceeds is
what you say when you haven't decided
how much you really want to help those
kids out now guys make no mistake though
this isn't a scam
this isn't a get rich quick scheme this
is melania wanting to share art with you
she wants to inspire you melania's
vision is a breathtaking watercolor art
by
guy
and embodies mrs trump's cobalt blue
eyes providing the collector with an
amulet to inspire okay i i don't know
what that is the limited edition piece
of digital artwork will be one solana
and includes a audio recording from mrs
trump with a message of hope now guys i
want to point out this limited edition
part of this because this is another
word that's sort of carrying a lot of
weight here by a limited edition they
sort of mean unlimited because looking
at the blockchain this doesn't seem to
have a limited quantity nowhere do they
say that a million people couldn't buy
this they just mint a new one every time
you buy it so is it limited if you it's
like you have a print you're just
printing it off and they're going it's
limited i i don't get it maybe just
because you can buy it until a certain
time i i suppose but for nfts where the
whole thing is like scarcity scarcity oh
there's it's like a one of one it's a
one of ten this is weird because just
like anyone can buy this thing and a lot
of people have guys going into this i
thought that people would see this for
what it is just another politician
suddenly caring about art suddenly
caring about nfts right as it's about
time to pay the mortgage but as usual i
was stunned by the stupidity by the
credulity of the followers of these
people already 391 people have bought
this nft for 182 dollars which if i
still know how to do math um brought her
about seventy one thousand dollars in a
few hours which hey
nft's baby she cares she cares
uh but yeah no i i really thought
everyone would see through this and no
one's gonna buy this right but you know
what i was wrong about i i just was in
my bubble right i was in my bubble of
you know people on twitter or whatever
who are sort of dunking on it but
there's this whole other contingent of
the population that i did not anticipate
i'm i i messed up and that portion of
the population is facebook judging from
these comments you would think that she
had just won the nobel peace prize you
never cease to amaze us thank you for
keeping us informed of all the wonderful
things you continue to do not only for
our children but also for our country
thank you melania for your ongoing
efforts to assist children in foster
care i mean
it's another world facebook right and
then of course you have this one
purchased minutes after launch thank you
so guys uh this actually does look like
it's going pretty well uh just just
shockingly because of course man in fact
i i honestly should have seen this
coming nfts are sort of everything that
politicians like they like making money
they like having to do almost no work
and they like rousing up their uh fan
base because you know this is getting
the fan base all juiced up on both sides
you know because the conservatives are
are
dunking on the libs by buying this
collection and the libs are pissed
giving this more fuel to the fire so i
expect quite frankly many more political
nfts in the future she says she's
dropping some nfts in january and i'm
sure she will continue but i think most
rational people look at this and they go
yes
easy cash grab off your followers but i
don't know if the followers care that's
that's the crazy thing either way
whether or not you know you think this
is a scam i do it's pretty clearly a
grip but either way this is a historic
moment i mean what's next boys is trump
gonna create the next tether i don't
know but whatever happens we're gonna
cover it we're gonna make fun of it as
it deserves to be but that's basically
it thanks for watching see ya